[Music]
hello everyone my name is Mohammed today
we'll be talking about building systems
to monitor model health in production
system it's a it's a mouthful so bear
with me today
so hello data Council I'm fairly new to
the community so thank you so much for
having me today and hello to everyone
else who is new to the community as well
a little bit about what I do I'm a
software engineer by background but
mostly focused on building tools as
decays and platforms for engineers and
data scientist I spend a lot of time
thinking about design patterns for
technical platforms built for engineers
data scientist and more previously I
spent a few years working at as a Data
Platform engineering team at Shopify
where I focused on building out its
libraries specifically leveraging
streaming technologies like Apache Kafka
right a little bit background about NASA
before I get started we build tools to
help machine learning engineers in
various enterprises scale up their
machine learning workflows specifically
we are aiming to build the same kind of
continuous delivery mechanisms as
regular software engineering but
specifically focused towards machine
learning our products include things
like Python SDKs schedulers and and more
currently I work on our suite which is
called foundations and foundations is
really our suite for continuous delivery
it's broken down into two products which
is Atlas which is available to download
for free actually and it said it's a
machine learning development tool that
converts your infrastructure into a
platform as a service that your data
scientists can collaborate on the second
tool which is going to be the focus of
my talk today is foundations orbit which
is really our tool for post production
model monitoring and maintenance so I'm
going to be talking about kind of the
design principles that we use there the
implementation details and what the
architecture looks like so you can
actually go in and either build a tool
similar similar to what we have in your
own company or or
I'll explore this further right okay
outside of machine learning you may have
seen us in the news as well we do some
fun side projects specifically the Joe
Rogan deep fakes and and we work we work
at a lot of blood astronomy and things
of that but that's a little bit about
death the agenda for today why do we
care about machine learning monitoring
and how it's different from traditional
software monitoring what are the things
that we should monitor what are the some
of the specifications we need to focus
on to build the monitoring system and I
will also show an example of our own
architecture and how you can leverage
that and also maybe copy that for your
own model monitoring system finally I'll
leave you with some more resources if
you want to understand the topic of
model monitoring a little bit better all
right first off why do we care about
machinery monitoring right so one of my
personal goals is to make sure that
machine learning is more accessible to
more and more companies it would just be
really great if to see more and more
products and services being improved by
machine learning but from working with
several companies that may that we found
that many of them really focus on the
model building part right so we have a
lot of companies out there who are doing
a lot of research they're building a lot
of models but very few actually
successfully put it into production
right or successfully do anything with
the moving it out of the proof of
concept stage and there is actually
quite a very few good reasons as to why
this happens first is production izing
something that is so dynamic and
probabilistic in nature is actually very
difficult right as soon as you put a
model in production it starts to degrade
because the data is is non-stationary
and your environment is non-stationary
right and we're also finding that an
increasing number of teams are getting
burned after putting missionarying in
production because they just don't have
the right kind of ecosystem the tools
needed so for example we worked with a
fortune 500 bank who built a really
solid fraud detection model it was
highly accurate the they you know they
celebrated their achievements right but
over a span of about eight months the
the model degraded so much in production
but the team was so busy monitoring many
other of their aspects that they didn't
really have the tools to automatically
leading to a lot of revenue loss for the
company right
second thing is most model management
tools right now are quite ad-hoc right
people in small organizations who are
shipping one or two models you know you
have some ad hoc processes maybe there
is the point person who is always
constantly monitoring the data running
different kinds of tests on it but to be
able to do this in a scalable manner
it's not possible at the moment and next
thing we often see this is that since
we're such an early stage of machine
learning especially we're putting it in
from enterprises very few companies are
actually thinking about SL A's or or
even maintaining SL A's in an automatic
fashion right so because very few
companies are doing this we're finding
that people are losing trust in the
models that they're putting in
production because they just don't have
the right tools to do that so it really
comes on to us which which I'm sure a
lot of you here are data infrastructure
engineers to be able to build different
kinds of platforms and different kinds
of tools that our data scientist can
leverage and and use to monitor other
things right cool
so what usually goes wrong imagine the
scenario right your company has embraced
ml significantly and you have several
models for each production from your
busy day you take some time to look at
some of the metrics of your model and
find that there is a steep decline right
and now you need to investigate what
what what happened but you notice this
and then you have to ask you sort of
various questions right is this a bug in
the upstream data that the model is
consuming you don't know that right is
this and if you want to dig into that
further do you do you know if any part
of your pipeline is particularly broken
or is it something that went wrong
during the future engineering stage or
is there a bug in the training source
code and why does it matter what did
someone deploy a new model right and if
someone did deploy me new model where is
the rest of the models right if I wanted
to rollback what is a rollback strategy
to be able to do that right along with
that there's other questions for example
are we under fearing are we overfitting
is the model not generalized enough
right to to work with the particular
data set right and there's other aspects
to it too as machine learning becomes
more and more fake more and more
accepted there could be adversarial
users and and many other things that
couldn't go wrong so really you need a
way a solid way to be able to
investigate and explore and figure out
further where things have gone wrong
right cool
and unlike and this is xkcd you put it
really well which is you know currently
most of the things that we do in machine
learning is quite non systematic right
wait more systematic ways to be able to
explore these aspects further cool so
the solution to that is really quite
simple actually which is something that
software engineers have been doing for
decades right which is writing tests but
more specifically we need to be able to
write tests and alerts on upstream data
sets for quality in every aspect of the
data pipeline we need to be able to keep
track and manage models in a centralized
store with versioning in them and have
an efficient rollback strategy and we
need to be able to evaluate models
continuously using real-world outcomes
and maintain predefined SLA s by setting
various thresholds and continuously
updating your models through automated
retraining and recalibration right
since this focus on this talk is purely
on monitoring so I'm gonna dig into that
a little bit further but if you want to
talk about Model Management and other
aspects I'll be happy to discuss that
during the office hour now we already do
a lot of monitoring for traditional
software engineering you know so
traditional software we can track our
source code changes through CI tools
like circle CI right and then we we do
infrastructure or network monitoring
there's lots of folks here from data dog
so you know things like that but when it
comes to machine learning not only do we
have to monitor that and we also have to
monitor infrastructure for machine
learning because if you have a model
that is doing online inference you need
to make sure that it's maintaining the
the uptime but along with that you also
have to do a lot of other kinds of
monitoring for example you have to
monitor data set shifts you have to
monitor whether you know things in in
the data pipeline have gone wrong you
have to make sure that there's a answer
there's a way for you to explain
different kinds of models and be able to
track all of these things right so
that's why machine learning monitoring
is slightly different from model
monitoring and on top of that this is
not helped with the process that before
in software engineering you would write
your code you would deploy your app and
then there would be a DevOps
team who would be able to take care of
your of your app and make sure that it's
healthy but with machine learning you're
not able to do that anymore because
right now you are the domain expert in
data science and you are the domain
expert of that of that model so if you
transfer it over to a completely
different team they may not have the
knowledge necessary to be able to tell
you how to update these models or
recalibrate them right cool so to be
able to monitor this we can have various
different strategies right there's a few
things so let's talk about each one of
the things that we would like to monitor
and we can and we can talk about that so
first thing is bugs in the data pipeline
right and this can happen when upstream
changes impact your downstream data
consumption example there could be
changes in the schema itself or there
could be a sudden disappearance of a
feature and this happens quite a lot
actually you'd be surprised many times
what can happen is you build a model and
you run it and let's say it's doing
online inference you're seeing that all
of a sudden a particular input feature
is a whole bunch of Nan's
or a whole bunch of minus nine and ninth
right and this could happen because
something something changed down the
line that your model wasn't expecting
right if it is an important feature then
that may impact your models quite
significantly right but there's
different strategies for us to be able
to monitor that what if we can write
expectations that will check a data set
as it goes through every aspect of my
pipeline right usually you will be using
a reference data set to be able to train
your model so what you can do then is to
create a sort of expectation all around
you pipeline that will compare the newer
data that is coming in to descent to the
standard that you have set with the
reference right and this expectation
should store various kinds of
information about your data set some of
the more important ones are for example
schema checks right min max ratio
special value checks uniqueness etc
right schema checks and all of these
things are quite important but but these
are things that have already been talked
about for a very long time and we
already know why they're important right
if the type of your if your if you if
one of your column changes you need to
be able to know that if if one of the
disappeared you need to be able to know
that so doing schema checks on a
continuous basis is quite important but
what I want to elaborate on really is
the special knowledge check that I mean
here now we have tools that existing
tools that do all of these things but
even then you need to be able to do this
in a continuous basis but for this
special knowledge tag we've seen this
happen quite a bit now you know
traditionally maybe you would build a
model that is using 50 features let's
say right but as we are going forward
with machine learning chances are you
will have models that use 100 200 300
400 different kinds of features and what
we have found is that usually in a
company there is someone who has some
special knowledge about a particular
data set or has special knowledge about
a particular data source and in software
engineering these kind of special
knowledge was was communicated to the
rest of the company by writing tests
write tests act as documentation in the
source code similarly tests in data
pipelines and data sets act as act as
documentation so what you can do is if
you have a way to codify the different
kind of special knowledge maybe you know
that hey this feature here can only be
it's a categorical feature and it can
only be a B and C right to be able to
write the test for that right and put
and codify that is going to be quite
important for you to share that
knowledge with the rest of the company
right ok so that's a little bit about
bugs in the data pipeline and that's one
of the things that we need to be
continuously monitoring as we are
talking about the monitoring system the
second thing that we need to monitor is
data set shifts and this is usually a
bit more difficult to monitor and a bit
more computationally intensive now after
deploying a missionary model in
production it will continue to provide
the estimates on the population it was
trained on but as the population shifts
over time the estimates become less and
less relevant on the current population
that you have right so simplistically
there's usually two types of data set
shifts that we need to monitor which is
input drifts and concept drifts right so
let's talk up that a little further
input drift is referring to the change
in the distribution of the input
variables present in the training and
inference data right
this occurs because datasets come from
non stationary environments which is
just which is true for any kind of data
set it may or may not actually
correspond to a drop in the model
performance but it can indicate problems
in your data distribution or or at the
same time it can also indicate problems
in and bugs in your pipeline right for
example you have a data set today that
uses customer demographics as a feature
right let's say it's a joint production
model and if your competitor produces a
new marketing campaign that is
specifically targeting the Millennial
customer base that you have that's going
to show up as a distribution shift in
the demographic feature that you have
within your model right or let's say you
have a bug in your pipeline that is
adding systemic noise skewing a bunch of
rows intermittently right this will also
show up as as a distribution shift
within your feature itself right now not
only can monitoring input drift in each
of your features help you make sure that
your model is performing the way it is
that your data sets are healthy that
your pipeline is healthy but it can also
help you be more proactive in choosing
better features to train on now why do I
say that so think about it this way
let's say you have a feature that gives
you a great result when you put it into
when you train your model with it but
you find out what time that this feature
itself actually is quite volatile and
when you put it in as a validation set
it changes quite rapidly
it may even though it may give you
better results and better accuracy you
may do a trade-off in volatility right
so you may not you may choose not to
include that as part of your training
data set right so being able to
continuously monitor your input drifts
in each one of your features allows you
to make sure that you are doing the
right kind of trade-offs between
volatility and accuracy or your metric
of choice right there's various ways for
us to be able to monitor input drifts
and this is a well studied well
documented approach of comparing
distributions right there's lots of
Papers written about it but the approach
that we take Edessa is
we want to make sure that whatever you
whatever the things that you write or
the things that you wider is easily
interpretable to the rest of the company
right so that you product managers and
others can set the right amounts of
expectations right so there's there's
three different ways so you can do you
can have a population stability index L
infinity checks similarity scores or you
can write a custom algorithm yourself I
personally prefer L infinity checks
because it allows you to it's very
easily interpretable right and and it's
also less computationally intensive so
it takes less a time to be able to get
that value up right but we can talk
about that letter and why you would
choose one algorithm over the other at a
later time cool so these are some of the
ways for you to be able to monitor input
drift right the next thing that comes up
is concept drift and concept shift
happens when the actual function the
probability distribution of the function
that you have that is mapping your
target your target to the input variable
actually changes and this can this
always shows up as a drop in the model
performance it usually indicates your
model needs to be trained again and
there's many reasons this can happen
actually let's take an example of an
e-commerce company all right doing
machine learning for predictive sale
analysis in this example one reason for
concept drift may be seasonality right
which means that you know shopping
behavior changes with time
all right so for example there may be
higher sales during the during Christmas
right and there may be lower sells
during summer and the demographic might
change right like during that time so
this can show up as as as concept if
that happens the important thing about
concept drift is that it can take many
different forms right it could be a
gradual change over time or it could be
a recurring or cyclical change right so
for example the seasonality aspect that
I've talked about or it could be a
sudden and abrupt change right maybe
you're an e-commerce company and
tomorrow is Black Friday right if it's
Black Friday you will see a strong
change in the demographics of your data
set so what different companies do
is if you once they monitor these things
and once they know or what to expect
with their datasets they will build they
may build different models for different
aspects of the time and they will swap
the models that are in production so if
it's a if it's a seasonality thing they
will probably use a different model that
is optimized with a different kind of
demographic right the main key aspect of
monitoring concept shift is making sure
that it is tied to a production metric
or a business metric that you can always
track right and this needs to be defined
by your data scientist at all time okay
cool we talked a lot about the some of
the different aspects of monitoring that
we would like to do right so bugs in the
data pipeline input drifts concepts and
these are some of the three fundamental
things that would be really good for you
to monitor there's other aspects as well
of monitoring like uncertainty
monitoring doing explain ability ways
and to make sure that some aspects of
your models are correct right but these
three fundamental ones can really help
you push your model push your models to
production faster right but to be able
to do this what we need to do is
essentially we need to be your data
scientist needs to be able to codify
expectations off data sets right they
need to be able to say that I expect
this data set to be of this particular
standard which has this much deviation
etc right essentially what they need to
do is if this is a traditional machine
learning workflow right you have your
data extraction layer which is all of
your ETL s which is being stored in your
data store and then you're doing some
data processing feature engineering once
you have a reference data set you're
essentially doing the training on it
and you go in this cycle here eventually
creating a train model which you may
store somewhere right once you have your
train model you can then put it into
production either as a cron based batch
online processing or you can do online
predictions through microservices but
but this is the traditional simple very
overly simplified way for you to do a
machine learning system but the main
point is you want to be able to set
expectations of data sets from every
single input and are
put that is coming into your pipeline
right because setting those expectations
and running these tests continuously
once things go wrong you can then tell
where in your pipeline things fell apart
right so it's very important for us to
be able to put expectations and run
tests on every single input and output
of the black box this these black boxes
can look different for your company
right but the whole point is you need to
be able to continuously monitor them
through tests right okay so the way we
solve this at Desa is through our
software is called orbit right and orbit
is a combination of a Python SDK a
scheduler and a GUI right that allows us
to do this kind of monitoring right the
Python SDK is used by our data
scientists to be able to write
expectations right which I'll talk about
shortly cool in orbit the the concept
that we have is we have a concept of a
data contracts object right it's data
contracts is just a Python class right
which stores a whole bunch of metadata
and that's really our way of defining
expectations using the orbit SDK to be
able to codify different kinds of
expectations every data contract is
essentially a configurable metadata
store that cannot be mutated once it is
life the reason for the immutable
immutability is the fact that we want to
be able to create a lineage of all the
changes that are happening to the
datasets as we go right so again I'm
gonna repeat every data contract object
is configurable meta store that cannot
be mutated
right all data contracts are also
versioned and all of these versions of
the contract needs to be updated to be
able to mutate it now essentially the
way it works is you take your reference
data set which is essentially a you know
a gold standard data data set that you
think every single data set coming in
needs to conform to you create did
update a contract out of it which is
your expectation and in that expectation
you will be defining different things
this is the this is the standard
deviation this is the special knowledge
check this is the XYZ right which we'll
talk about further
and then orbit will continuously use the
newer data set and continuously monitor
them along with the data contracts right
so this is really our way to be able to
configure and set expectations for any
kind of reference data set now I'll
showcase the how the Python SDK works
right here right so this is kind of our
approach to be able to use the data
contract so what you can see here is I'm
importing the data contract library and
then I'm creating a data contract giving
it a name and Orbitz will automatically
version them and I'm creating I'm
passing in reference data frame right
once I pass in a reference data frame
I'm going to be saving the data contract
which is essentially it turns it into a
pickle file with a whole bunch of
metadata right and I'll save this data
contract into a particular registry and
it's very important for your company to
be able to maintain a registry of all
the data contracts so that you can
maintain a lineage like I mentioned
earlier once I do this using the Python
SDK itself I can configure various
aspects of the data contract so I can
say things like hey this contract with
this data set needs to conform to this
this kind of L infinity check right or
there needs to be at any point in time
this particular column can only have
this many number of Nan's
or this many number of standard
deviation or different kinds of other
checks that you would do right along
with that I mentioned earlier that you
know there's few things a data science
is evolving so rapidly
right so the checks that you would do in
your data in your data sets may change
rapidly
and so you need to be able to write your
own algorithms and add them as
monitoring right second aspect is that
your your your machine learning
engineers need to be able to essentially
keep up with the newer methods that are
coming in and be able to codify them so
what we also did is we provided a way
for our machining engineers to create
custom methods and pass them and pass
them into the data contract itself right
to do that they can define any kind of
algorithm that they want on the
particular types of column but there is
some stuff that comes out of the box
right once you configure these things
you will be essentially running a
validation report and this validation
will will be done in a different kind in
a different script that you will write
right so you write the script and then
that script will be continuously be
running in the background right on a
different cluster it will be pulling the
data set from whatever you define
whether it's Kafka whether it's a your
sequel database whatever it is it'll
pull the data set and it will run
continuous validations comparing it to
the data contract that you stored
earlier right once you did this all of
these reports get surfaced into a GUI
through the REST API and in this REST
API you are able to essentially see all
the schema checks the population shift
and all the custom tests there right so
this is really our way to be able to
configure different kinds of metadata
about a particular later and
continuously run these tests right ok
dot data contract concept works really
well to be able to find input drift and
to be able to do bugs in your data
pipeline but it falls apart when you are
doing a concept drift because in concept
drift not only do you have to monitor
those things but you also have to
monitor different kind of algorithms
that are tied into your own business
logic so what we what we do it for our
data scientists is provide them ways to
track different kinds of production
metrics right whether its accuracy the
revenue you number of active customers
anything that the data scientist have
the power to decide which algorithm our
what to use to tie into the business
metric all of these things eventually
get fed back into the into the into the
validation report right which gets
monitored on a continuous basis right
and these the country that the the way
we do continuous is I'm going to define
that shortly but this is essentially you
can use not only you can use something
like this but you can also use something
like data dog if you're already part of
the data dog ecosystem right cool
so what happens at the end by giving our
data scientist the ability to do these
things we now have the
ability to write expectations so every
Greenfield is an expectation we have the
ability to write expectations and every
aspect of our data pipeline right for
example in the training data set I can
now write a data contract that is taking
this training reference data set as a
meta data and then publish it to orbit
and orbit will continuously monitor this
process to make sure anything that new
that is coming in is conforming to that
data set right cool before I jump into
the architecture of the of orbit itself
we mentioned that we need to be able to
monitor bugs in the pipeline which is
two data contracts and concept chip but
there's also other criterias that we
need to think about before we build the
monitoring system within the company
some of them are the first thing is it
needs to be a sidecar or async async'
architecture the reason for this is that
doing this validation checks on such big
data pipelines is very computationally
intensive and it takes a long time so
you don't want them to be tied into the
cluster that is running your app right
or running the production model it all
of these things should be happening in
the background and should be having
asynchronously along with that you need
to be able to provide some standard
monitoring features for example schema
checks min maxes L infinity checks that
I talked about right which your data
scientists can don't have to define
again and be able to just use
automatically right next up is you need
to be able to define custom monitors so
that's where the custom method comes in
right we need to be able to define
custom lambda functions so that we can
run different kinds of algorithms on
each one of our functions and then this
this is where the scheduling comes in
right once you create this monitors not
only do you need to be able to do this
do these checks on a cron based schedule
so for example you could say like hey
run this monitoring every single day at
this particular time right not only do
you have to do that but you also have to
do it on an event based approach because
for example if you have a Kafka system
you want to be able to say like hey as
soon as I'm produce produce I'm
consuming a particular topic
triggered this monitoring system right
or as soon as this data set is available
triggered the monitoring to make sure
that it is conforming to it lastly you
need a way to be able to view all of
these things in in a centralized place
and at the same time be able to set
thresholds on them so that people get
notified the code owners get notified of
each one of them so whoever the project
owner of that is cool so what this
eventually leads us to is an
architecture like this right
so what we have here is the you know
data contacts approach that I talked
about earlier but this is what the
architecture that we built for orbit
essentially your data scientists use our
use the Python SDK to be able to write
different kinds of monitors right and
each monitor is essentially a Python
script you can think about right and in
that Python script they will be defining
where to pull the data contract from
where to pull the data sources from so
where's the input gonna be what is the
reference data set and and to be able to
run the different kinds of validators
that we talked about earlier when each
one of these monitors you create you
create each one of these monitors for
every single aspect of your pipeline
that you want to monitor and then you
publish it to orbit right and you
publish it through our REST API and once
you do that you can then set triggers to
run this monitors right so you can say
like hey run this monitor at this
particular time or run this monitor when
the new data set is available or when a
different kind of event happens all of
those things then eventually get fed
into the into our data store and in that
data store our REST API pulls up all the
validation reports and you can then view
them in a centralized place across all
of your data science projects that you
have ongoing so now with this ability
you have this way for you to be able to
monitor every single aspect of your
pipeline across all of your data science
projects right eventually from from the
GUI itself you can set various kinds of
thresholds so you can say things like
hey as soon as the PSI ships by 0.1
notify X in on page of duty are notified
on slack or send them an email right to
make sure that they know what's going on
right that's really the heart of it one
of the more important aspects of it is
to make sure that you have the ability
to store all these data contracts in a
centralized place because disability
will eventually tell you a history of
every single data every single data
lineage that is happening across all of
your pipelines right so this so doing
this versioning and doing this immutable
approach is very very important for
YouTube mater so concretely speaking
this is the data scientist workflow that
we would be having you create a data
contract here that you can see I'm
defining different kinds of min Max's
tests I'm setting different kinds of
lower bounds or I could do my own custom
method if I wanted right and so you can
set different kinds of threshold there
and then I'm saving the data contract
currently I'm saving this locally but
you could you would traditionally be
saving it into your own contract
registry right and then you would place
this data contracts in your validation
code so you can see here that I have a
valid PI right and this is the
monitoring code that I will be running
on a cron based approach some loading
the data contract and I'm running the
valve date on the x inference that I've
received that I got earlier from my data
store once I do that I will deploy the
validation pipeline right on using a
leasing foundations monitor which is
orbit and that will be deployed on the
cluster on the monitoring cluster that I
have built in right once that is done
all of my monitor scripts will be in
this single project so you can see I
have a fraud project here right and I
have to monitoring scripts here right
and then I can go into each one of them
schedule different kinds of like timing
right or I can set an event based one
and orbit will automatically generate
validation reports on a cut owner on a
continuous basis after that I can go
into and see each and all the validation
results and I can see things like hey
the out-of-the-box ones like schema
checks population share special values
min maxes etc I can continuously see
which one is doing what right I can see
that hey this population chef here
there's something critical that has gone
wrong maybe one of the features have
shifted quite a lot so I can
go into that and dig into that further
and then I can set different kinds of
like thresholds to be able to monitor
them on a continuous basis right that's
all uh we covered a lot today I want to
quickly summarize what we did what have
we talked about the first thing we
talked about is why monitoring is
important right and how monitoring
machine learning models is different
from monitoring traditional software
right we also talked about some of the
three fundamental ones that we should
monitor right bugs in the data pipeline
in every aspect of your pipeline being
able to monitor data set shifts through
input drifts and concept drift and then
we talked about how our framework off
off doing it which is using data
expectations data contracts which act as
expectations for your for every single
aspect of your pipeline and then lastly
we talked about the architecture that we
built which is the sidecar architecture
that runs on a separate cluster which
can run all this monitoring on an
event-based or a cron base schedule to
be able to validate your reports on a
continuous basis right that's all I have
today thank you very much appreciate it
and I'll take some questions if there's
any awesome talk I love that we have
independently converged on using
expectations you talked about special
special knowledge checks I'm curious
what that means in the framework right
so what we've found is that there are
there are individuals within that
company who know something special about
about a data set right what I mean by
that is they have this particular
knowledge about it which others don't
right for example someone may be really
deep down into a into a particular data
set or a particular workflow right
working on a project and they may have
this like intuition about about
something right or they may have some
more concrete formal ideas like this is
a categorical feature and it can only
have a B and C categories right but you
need to be able to qualify those things
right and write them as expectations
right so that people get so that you
know a it acts as documentation for the
rest of your company right and B all of
this special
which ones are maintained and
continuously checked got it does that
kind of make sense it does yeah and what
I wasn't sure is are you like pausing
the pipeline to ask somebody a question
like look at this it sounds like no
instead you're saying hey prior to
running the pipeline let's generate a
lambda together that's right that's
right that's exactly it so no we're not
telling anyone to stop the pipelines
right it's it's whoever is working on
the project itself it's up to them to be
able to make sure that they're creating
the lambda functions that are able to
monitor those things right thank you
[Music]